the key to biohacking is understanding
that your body doesn't do a very good
job of listening to you
it listens to the world around you if
you want to do personal development
you want to meditate you want to improve
your brain doing it on french fries
doesn't it doesn't work you have to get
your biology in order
there's a set of studies that show if
you go for a walk for 20 minutes a day
that that increases mitochondrial
function that's it
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
dave asprey and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one eliminate
suspect foods the key to biohacking is
understanding that your body
doesn't do a very good job of listening
to you it listens to the world around
you
and it listens to what it perceives to
be threats so
one of the things that chews up the most
energy throughout the day is
actually thinking and obsessing about
food
so what if you could do something that
made it so that
after you finished a meal you didn't
think about food until the next meal and
even when the next meal came around
you're like
i could eat or not but it wasn't like
will it be tacos for lunch is it lunch
time yet is it lunch time yet and that
voice that most of us have in our head
it's unnecessary and is hugely
distracting from all the things that
are more important so how do you do that
the first thing you do is you say all
right how did i feel after my last meal
and if you're hungry within a half hour
or an hour of your meal guess what you
did it wrong
it means you ate something that you're
that is actually causing inflammation in
your body
it means you found a food that's
incompatible with your system and it
turns out there is no one universal diet
for human beings
there are basic rules and the first rule
is stop eating the stuff that makes you
weak
and in the bulletproof diet this is my
book that sold somewhere
around half a million copies in 17
languages
there's a roadmap and it's free it's on
the bulletproof website bulletproof
roadmap you can look for it
and what it does it tells you okay here
are the proteins and fats and carbs and
vegetables
that are generally safe it'll cause
problems for almost anybody here's the
set of things called
suspect foods and you know what for a
lot of people these cause problems would
you believe a third of people can't
digest kale and it makes them have sugar
cravings
right or tons of people it's grains
and beans and legumes or bell peppers
and the nightshade family or potatoes or
tomatoes
you wouldn't know it but if you're
eating this every day you're gonna
constantly be foggy
tired have a little bit of muffin top
and it's just your condition
people don't know that a third of
rheumatoid arthritis is caused by
basically potatoes and tomatoes but what
well since you don't know that what if
you just stopped all of that stuff
for just a week and at the end of the
week whoa the sky is brighter
i like my life i like my wife uh and my
joints don't hurt
and i just realized i should start a
company look maybe something you're
doing before in that list of suspects
was actually guilty and then there's
also a list of kryptonite foods and
these are
things like don't eat those like you
wanted to show up all the way in the
world that's not for humans
and so eliminate the suspect food per
week that's one biohack
rule number two learn from elders in
all societies that i studied and it's in
like the first chapter of superhuman i
talk about
the quest for immortality is uh
something that's happened as long as
we've
had recorded history going back to the
egyptians going back to
the alchemists going back to the hindu
traditions the chinese traditions the
south american traditions they've all
been searching for this
and things like taoism are tied directly
towards that quest for how do i live
forever as a highly functioning highly
energetic evolved person
well we've always had village elders so
what would happen is the young
monks would go into the monastery and
the 80 year old llama
will look at them and say all right
here's what we've learned and i learned
this from
my elders and i learned it from my
elders
in fact lao zeus tradition 5 000 years
of unbroken oral history passed down
from
the elders well elders today
unfortunately
a lot of them alzheimer's disease heart
attacks
retirement homes and we started seeing
our elders rather than as sources of
knowledge and wisdom
the people who can guide us the best we
started seeing them as
tubes monitors diapers wheelchairs and
expenses
and that's actually never happened
observation yeah all of history doesn't
happen great observation
so i go out of my way to interview
people who are over 90. because
man they've got you know 50 years on me
and what did they learn that i'm
probably going to learn and what can
they
what pain can i avoid from listening to
them rule number three
exercise i looked at all the research on
mitochondria and exercise like what's
what's going to make them
stronger what's not going to make them
stronger there's a set of studies that
show if you
go for a walk for 20 minutes a day that
that increases mitochondrial function
that's it that's it
now that's one set of studies you can go
for longer but if you go for too long
you actually can stress them out
which isn't a good thing so you know if
you're going to every day go for it you
know two hour run
without recovery it's the lack of
recovery that
really messes up your energy system so
you see a lot of people who are
type a entrepreneurs like you or me
where you know we like to go outside
yeah and they're like and on top of that
i'm gonna like run a kona iron man
and i'm gonna do it without sleep just
because i could right
so you push like that and i've certainly
done that you know in my early career
in in tech that the company that held
google's first servers and things like
that
i i'm i'd burn the i'm like why did you
burn the count of both ends when you
could also light the middle
right like it is so bad for you and it's
bad for you because it breaks your
mitochondria like they get
stressed like that and they communicate
with each other right
and they do that with uh they deal with
chemicals and we believe
that they probably do it with light as
well which is really interesting
if those theories are proven and i would
bet right now
that they will be we know that these
little parts of your cells
make lights the same way an led light
does they literally make little photons
and they receive photons
so a set of scientists are proposing
that that's how
mitochondria talk which is why if you're
beating up your muscles all the time
you're going to be tired in your head
because the whole system of these
bacteria that are interacting and
they're not bacteria anymore they're
part of our cells they're called
organelles
but they still have that little bit of
bacterial behavior that's built in
and that allows us to be who we are and
what we are so it's fascinating
yeah go ahead the other exercise just so
i yeah like so people listening i
don't leave them going i just have to go
for a walk once or maybe twice a week
but certainly once a week you need to
kick your ass
and there's two ways to do it and these
are actually both in the bulletproof
diet too because we knew they worked but
we didn't understand the mitochondrial
part of that back then
one is intermittent sprinting yes
basically sprint for 60 seconds
and there's a neat trick in headstrong
that's not in the first book and i got
this from john gray
uh the uh the men are from mars yeah
yeah
that guy huh he is a crazy biohacker you
would not know this from reading his
books about relationships no he
he goes deep so we got to be friends and
he's like dave after you sprint instead
of walking lay on your back
just lay down like the way you're seeing
a cross fidget and people just kill
themselves and lay down
there's a reason they're doing that
they're not doing it because they know
the reason they're doing it because they
they felt the urge and that was
going to be whenever i would do crossfit
to lay down it's because i could
couldn't breathe and i was just like
yes well that's the body's natural
response so if you want to
increase the height and the trough which
is what you're doing you're telling
those guys you better be ready to just
like bring it all at once
you're training the battery in your body
to totally have a high voltage and then
stop
so so you should stop and go on your
back
yeah at least sit down better yet lay
down really for a minute and then get up
and sprint again and then lay down and
this is what animals will do right
that's true and it's it it's amazing
what a difference that is so that's one
way you kick your ass the other way is
lift heavy things for 15 minutes or less
and don't stop keep the muscles engaged
the entire time don't stop at the top
don't stop at the bottom
as heavy as you can and you'll while
stretching and warming up properly
why would you do that exactly yeah i do
my warm-ups on the
on the bulletproof vibe you know i'm
vibrating when i do that sure sure uh
and i
i do that vibration stuff every day or i
go for a walk but quite often i'm on the
phone and
it's i'm in canada it's dark and raining
like vancouver right yeah i think
violence yeah yeah i'm on an organic
farm
rule number four push yourself one of
the things you learn if you
if you go to any ancient practice
lineage look we're all going to die and
even when i talk to my
immortalist friends you know those super
long jobs i'm going to upload myself to
the internet
news flash the universe will collapse in
on itself sometimes we're all going to
die you just have to get used to that
yeah
and a lot of people oh i don't want to
sorry that's just a fact of life
the question is how much suffering do
you want to do before you die that's
really what we're doing
and for me i actually don't like
suffering it's amazing but
discomfort is different than suffering
so anytime you
do something that makes your brain or
your body evolve it will involve
discomfort
but suffering comes when you resist the
discomfort and understanding all right
i'm feeling a lot of emotional
discomfort right now
but it doesn't mean i'm suffering
doesn't mean i'm struggling it means i'm
accepting
and all right it's a signal so i'm
lifting this heavy thing i'm really sore
the next day
that was the cost of growth or i'm
facing my fears and i'm doing it anyway
and i feel like i'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
and i'm gonna do it anyway
and i'm gonna see what happens that's
how our brain evolves we're wired to do
to focus on things that don't push us
yes because that's biology yes well
once you decide you're going to take
charge and you're going to push yourself
you say all right maybe i will live to
180 maybe i'll live beyond 180
or maybe i'll just you know ask someone
out who i'm really afraid to ask why the
hell are you afraid to ask someone out
the worst they'll do is say no
it's the same as saying look do you like
pizza or chinese okay if they say i like
pizza like darn i'd like chinese we're
not compatible it's not a judgment on
you
but if you don't ask you don't know yeah
but people think of all this
crazy programming in their heads i got
rid of most of my crazy programming just
through these
these processes and i don't think i
could have
the the power to do that if i hadn't
have just gotten my base biology working
with
food and so we get wrapped up in all
these fears and resistance things
but really the simplest lows hanging
fruit here is just eat the stuff that
makes your brain work
and then you'll start being comfortable
pushing yourself otherwise you're just
too tired to push yourself
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief
the link to join absolutely for free is
in the description below
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming
you have to go build self-confidence
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected rule number
five implement
fasting if mitochondria are the source
of
aging you threw out a couple things
really faster that we can do
to protect against that or to optimize
our mitochondria
what does that look like there's about a
quadrillion mitochondria in your body
way more than there are bacteria in your
gut and way way more than there are
cells in your body
so your neurons in your brain have 15
000 mitochondria
in one cell and these things have their
own little unique consciousness
cell level consciousness like a bacteria
would have you know very basic things
that they do
but it's become this elegant dance where
inside a neuron
these mitochondria will move back and
forth and it'll break in half and and
they do
stuff that is at the very very core of
life stuff we didn't understand
20 30 years ago because we couldn't see
it we couldn't measure it
and one of the things that they do is
they hang around even if they don't work
very well
that means that if you don't provide
enough stress for them they will not
go to the biologically expensive trouble
of killing the weak ones and replacing
them with fresh young ones interesting i
didn't know that
so it's kind of like a cell in your
battery right you're
in your tesla even in your phone there's
multiple cells in your battery and if
one of the cells goes bad the battery
the phone keeps working doesn't charge
quite as well
two of the cells go bad eventually
enough the cells go bad it only holds
the charge for five minutes
you're in the hospital your phone's
getting replaced well
what if there was a way to say oh the
cell's going wrong let me kick that cell
out and grow a fresh new cell that's
what our bodies do
and when you do things like fasting
and you just don't eat breakfast it's
not that hard or don't eat for a couple
days
when you do that all the cells that
cannot survive
because they're freaking out i don't
mean your cells i mean the cells within
the cells the mitochondria
they'll actually die through a process
called autophagy
and when that happens your body cleans
out the dead ones
and you grow fresh new young ones rule
number six experiment
how did you get the idea i think the
bulletproof coffee was the first
big one that you built your business
with how did that come about and
how did it guess did that transition
into the supplements and this whole
movement
well for 20 years i've run an anti-aging
nonprofit group
in silicon valley and i've been learning
from
people two three times my age who are
really going out there and figuring out
here's what you can actually do
and i realized there was this whole
hidden world of those people but they
didn't talk to the neuroscientists they
didn't talk to the meditation people
and as i was working on fixing my stuff
i said all right
i'm going to do what's not supposed to
work i'm going to go learn meditation
from the masters
and now today your i would say that's
pretty cool but one of the reasons
meditation is cool
today is that almost 10 years ago i
guess eight years ago in 2011 when i
started the bulletproof vlog
no one would admit they meditated right
if you were an exec in silicon valley
and you said yoga meditation
smart drugs you were an alien so i put
in my linkedin profile
yeah and the idea was i'm going to make
this stuff cool because it works
so i went to tibet and i'm on the side
of mount kailash there's a five-day
four-wheel drive
in the middle of nowhere it's the
holiest mountain in the world
it's considered the mountain olympus of
buddhists
and hindus and 10 degrees below zero
eighteen thousand feet
i'm feeling like crap that's how you're
supposed to feel yeah little tibetan
lady gives me a bowl of yak butter tea
and i drink it and within a minute like
my brain just turned on i feel
so good this is unbelievable so i came
back to silicon valley and i said all
right
buy some butter and some tea and it
tasted gross and it didn't work
and it kind of pissed me off like this
can't be so i started experimenting with
25 different butters and all these
different teas and different coffee
and i figured out oh the coffee usually
made you crash after you drank it
and i realized there's something i can
do with my coffee as well my very first
blog post for bulletproof was here's how
you can make bulletproof coffee
and i hadn't launched any products yet
it was like hey usually you can blend
some things seriously you can do all
these different things
and i also created this term biohacking
i created a movement around it to get
the anti-aging people the
neuroscientists the navy seals
the bodybuilders the power lifters the
pro athletes to all talk about this
common thing
including medical professionals and
astronaut trainers and whatever else
people were doing
that was all about human performance and
i don't care if you're a sleep doctor
uh or you're at the gym you teach people
how to put muscle on faster
you are helping people get control of
their own biology so i defined the term
i created an infographic and i didn't
trademark
the term biohacking i said our community
needs a name this is to bring people
together
and i trademarked bulletproof but
biohacking just became a thing and
last year merriam-webster's added it to
the dictionary as a new word in english
language and i'm there in the definition
which is
super cool but it's now a thing and
there's millions of people who identify
themselves as
i'm a biohacker i want to control my
biology so i took it
rule number seven practice cold showers
mitochondria their job is to stay alive
and then their job is also to kill off
the weak
so you got to stress them enough to kill
off the weak and
that process is is called apoptosis if
you don't do that you get cancer
so you want to you want to stress you
want to stress them but not too much so
it's brief periods of stress
so there's like ice ice is great jobs or
ice showers
yeah just a cold shower in the morning
not a whole cold shower because cold
showers suck
let's face it yeah just take a hot
shower at the end turn it on cold do it
all at once
and just feel the pain for a minute
those little guys they're going to freak
out that makes them stronger
they get stronger and the weak ones die
right and then
you burn more calories throughout the
day your brain is clear and inflammation
goes down
and here's the interesting thing every
time you have inflammation it's because
your mitochondria aren't working very
well
so if something makes you inflamed it's
because you damaged
your battery system in the body when
things are working well
they actually change the structure of
the water in your body
it's called exclusion zone water and no
one knew mitochondria could do this
until a couple years ago gerald pollock
figured this out and he talked about it
at the bulletproof conference
so all of a sudden you're just telling
these little guys hey
the world isn't always warm and soft and
fuzzy maybe you should just toughen up a
little bit
and then that toughness gets built into
your system and you carry it with you
for the rest of the day and so you're a
little leaner
you're a little just just more on point
and it cost you nothing in fact you
saved a quarter cent on eating hot water
for that last one
like it was just a change in habit rule
number eight
take care of your body we used to think
oh we don't know why we age we age
because of time
you know we age because of whatever
but it's not one thing and it's sort of
like why does your car break
well is it because you didn't change the
oil you didn't put gas in the tank you
didn't change the tires you didn't
rotate the timing belt and all the other
stuff you do to maintain a car
and did you do it at the right time
throughout the life of the car if you do
it right there's cars with 700
000 miles on them and driving today and
there's cars in the junkyard with 70 000
miles
right i'd like this to be a 700 000 mile
car it might have a few wrinkles in the
seats
but it's perfectly serviceable and it
gets around under its own power
and this is doable but only if you know
the maintenance schedule
so the seven pillars in superhuman are
about those
for each of the pillars there's things
you can do that are
free that are lifestyle based there's
things you can do that are pretty cheap
like maybe change your diet a little bit
or
take a supplement or a small gadget
let's say
and then there are things that are based
on the very cutting edge science
some of them are frighteningly expensive
but this is what the millionaires are
doing
and i went to the trouble of going out
and doing as many of those as i could
afford or find
and those things are are in here so
here's the experience of doing it here's
you know an expert here's
my own assessment of this and here's the
results i had
and what i want people to walk away from
this interview from reading the book
just from thinking about this aging is
death by a thousand cuts
and these seven pillars are what are
holding you up but what if you
took less cuts they were less deep and
then you healed those cuts
like wolverine instead of just putting
band-aids on them
you'll find that when you're old you
have a lot less scars and you function a
lot better and actually
you're not old you just have lots of
years and that is the path that i'm on
and it's an accessible achievable path
for everyone
rule number nine understand biohacking
what would you say
you know biohacking what would you
define it i guess as because
you know a lot of people might think
biohacking has to be this you know crazy
experiment that you do on yourself but
it could be the simple things about what
you do with your sleep or small
improvements that just
i guess allow you to get more out of
yourself but how would you i guess
define it
it's the art and science of changing the
environment around you and inside of you
so that you have full control of your
biology and what that does is that means
look the control i wanted enough energy
to have an hour commute home at the end
of a day
and then have enough energy to play with
my kids take care of the house and then
go to sleep and rinse and repeat and be
a good provider
okay that is control because a lot of
people you come home you're too tired
you just want to have a drink or you you
just i don't have energy to deal with my
kids right now stuff like that
it's real okay that's a level of control
that a lot of people don't have that
they want
or i just want the ability to look at a
cookie and not eat it this is a problem
for me when i weigh 300 pounds
like i'm not gonna do it and eventually
the cookie wins the war against my
willpower and then i eat half the cookie
i'm like why am i a loser
right well i'm not a loser that's just
the voice in my head but
that that thing well all of those are
control or maybe you want to be the
fastest in the world or maybe you want
to
have you know a 16 pack or whatever the
thing is your goals can be all over the
place but the techniques the rules the
algorithms the things you do
they're the same and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is cut out msg things that contain msg
have to go and there's still a group of
science trolls to say there's no
evidence that msg is bad for you like
except for like
a gazillion pieces of evidence that you
chose to ignore
so msg causes hypoglycemia
restaurants buy spices
that are 74 msg by volume and they're
not
required to be labeled as msg spice
extractives
paprika extract garlic extract a lot of
the extracts and flavorings natural
flavoring sometimes
the food companies sell these in
magazines
and catalogs saying does not have to be
labeled as msg
they know it's msg but according to fda
law
that's just probably usda law but 75 or
above
is msg when you eat this or let's say
you're running a restaurant you want to
make more money
put something into the food that has msg
in it that isn't labeled your chef can
can without even knowing it's in there
will be oh no there's no msg i checked
the label
when people eat this it's going they're
going to like the food because
it tastes good right but they're also
going to increase the order by about 30
percent
because they're going to order more
drinks because they get thirsty and
they're going to order dessert because
they got hypoglycemia
guess what hypoglycemia is it's a lack
of energy going into the inputs in the
batteries in your cells so you feel like
you need more well they start
creating a panic response it's like give
me sugar baby and that's where sugar
cravings are coming from
so yeah you gotta not eat msg it's just
not there
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you get motivated inspired you have
a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated inspired and you create a
plan of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through and when you share with other
people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood
of following through and so i want that
to be you from this video we don't just
watch videos here believe nation
we do something we take action so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you if you
want to do personal development
you want to meditate you want to improve
your brain doing it on french fries
doesn't it doesn't work you have to get
your biology in order
because if your cells don't make energy
it's
subcellular components that drive most
of your felt state
and if they're running a half power how
you can have enough energy to
wake up you know have whatever you have
in the morning
take care of of yourself take care of
your family your community oh and had
time and energy left over to do the deep
personal work too if you let go of a
childhood thing or
you know reach a new state of
performance no you were too tired
because your cells didn't work
so eat right and then do the meditative
practice and you'll get more results in
less time
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there